bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur rtl france est ce que cette
procédure de contentieux va aider les
pêcheurs français à court terme
mais je crois que sa firme d'ap tout
d'abord que le gouvernement français
soutient et défend les pêcheurs volley
français il est important de milliers
d'actions de contentieux contre le
royaume uni à partir du moment où cet
accord les parties entre l'union
européenne et le royaume uni n'est pas
respectée donc ce sera dans la durée ce
contentieux il n'empêche la aujourd'hui
il faut d'abord et avant tout continuer
les négociations pour justement régler
les quelques dernières dizaines de
licence qui restent en suspens qui ne
sont pas malheureusement aujourd'hui
attribué aux navires français qui ont ce
droit et ce droit qui est
confirmée validé par tous les éléments
que nous avons transmis vous êtes donc
satisfait par la posture du gouvernement
français
on est satisfait que le plan la
république est vraiment en soutien avec
la ministre de la mer et le ministre des
affaires européennes a aujourd'hui c'est
la commission européenne qui doit jouer
son rôle de deux rôles de deux fois
contraint de l'eau réunit de pouvoir
donné ses licences à senna lire et donc
aujourd'hui nous sommes on se tient
après du président de la république
lui-même envers les professionnels
maintenant il nous faut
des preuves qui permettent justement de
donner ses licences de pêche aux bateaux
aux bretons mais aussi normand et ou de
france qu'elle soit dans les îles anglo
normandes ou qu'elle soit sur les eaux
territoriales britanniques est ce que
c'est une procédure de contentieux a
lancé par la france donc à l'encontre du
royaume uni avoir des conséquences sur
le travail des pêcheurs au quotidien
lorsqu'ils naviguent on évoquait en
temps des petites vengeances britannique
une forme de harcèlement est ce que
c'est quelque chose que vous craignez
oui c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui laurie
ameline
et vraiment avec le gouvernement et le
premier ministre boris johnson et du
mauvaise foi assuré auprès de ces
pêcheurs et surtout fait cas aujourd'hui
ils augmentent les voir ils imposent des
règles qui ne sont il n'ya latéral mise
en place quand leur mini qui
complètement illégal dans cet accord que
deux têtes des règles de mesure
technique de cet échange est validée
avec l'union européenne et de plus il
l'intensification troll voir harcèle
ouvertement sans aucune vergogne des
contrôles auprès des navires français et
européens et on voit bien d'ailleurs le
déplacement des soties dans les eaux
européennes de crainte de se retrouver
dans des difficultés auprès de bureaux
et midi dans les eaux qui les concernent
moi je crois qu'il est important que le
précédent de la république l'affirmé
confirmé la france affirmera sans droits
et ces droits en tant que tel auprès de
du royaume uni il souhaite d'ailleurs
mettre en place le conseil de
partenariat au-delà du contentieux qui
sera mis en oeuvre par la france le plus
tôt possible et dès le début d'année je
crois qu'il est important aussi que l on
continue c'est un axe de dialogue avec
le royaume uni mais aussi avec l'en
bilatérales avec jersey de façon à ce
qu'on puisse si nous n'arrivons pas avec
le rhume unis on puisse le faire
localement ce qui peut permettre
peut-être le débloquer certaines
situations
et puis pour ceux qui me font port ne
pourront pas avoir ne peuvent pas avoir
cet acte est ce qu'on espère le leu leu
sur cale peine à lire potentiel qui
n'ont pas tous les éléments
potentiels
le ministre la ministre et le ministre
des affaires européennes avec le présent
publics ont aussi réfléchi à pouvoir
être en aide auprès des professionnels
de qui seront concernés donc je crois
qu'il est important de dire aussi que le
présent le public a une vision
stratégique qui est de mettre en place
un plan d'action de pêche durable avec
la ville de nevers pour redonner de la
visibilité aux professionnels malgré les
contraintes que connaissent cette
filière qui va au delà du brésil les
contraintes de dérèglements climatiques
qui vont aussi dans des problématiques
de transition énergétique d'attractivité
du métier donc je crois qu'il est
fondamental est indispensable
aujourd'hui que la france soit à côté de
ces pêcheurs ce que doit être aussi la
commission européenne alors pour rester
sur cette crise des licences de pêche
post break site le gouvernement français
a donc vous l'évoquiez annoncé lancer un
plan d'accompagnement pour indemniser
les pêcheurs il évoque du coup du mans
du cas par cas bassin par bassin je le
cite quel est votre regard
mais je crois que certains navires
malheureusement peut-être n'ont pas
assez de
d'éléments qui vont permettre de la
continuité de leur dollar accès d'un
saison en bretagne nous avons 28 navires
ils sont prioritaires nous souhaitons et
nous exigeons que ce droit est que ces
licences soient attribués à ces navires
avec aussi quatre navires qui sont dans
les eaux territoriales britanniques au
même titre que il se pose toujours la
question des navires remplaçants qui
sera indispensable et discuter et
surtout ce qu'a rappelé le le plaisant
république il souhaite dès demain le
plus tôt possible ont commencé à
échanger et à discuter sur la praye 2026
car ce que l'on discute là aujourd'hui
ce ne sont que sur les licences des îles
anglo normandes et métalliques avec des
mesures techniques qui vont unir eu par
la suite est très très rapidement en
2026 donc on doit renégocier la totalité
de ces accords et donc il est
indispensable de se mettre au travail
dès maintenant pourquoi être rendez-vous
en 2006 car la bataille sera rude à
nouveau avec le royaume oui parce qu'on
parle beaucoup aujourd'hui de des
licences mais il ya aussi la question
des modalités de pêche des quotas des
espèces des questions techniques aussi
tout ça est en cours de discussion avec
londres ça annonce d'autres combats
costaud dans les prochains mois
oui tout à fait dans les prochains mois
ça va être une bataille je l'aiderai une
négociation éternelle comme l'a rappelé
d'ailleurs le président de la région
bretagne car nous nous sommes partis sur
une sortie d'un état d'un ex états
membres qui avec des zones de pêche qui
sont importants pour la france mais
aussi pour d'autres pays européens a
aujourd'hui c'est la france qui est en
première ligne je crois qu'il y a le
soutien d'autres des autres pays
européens et on se doit d'avoir une une
commission européenne l'europe aux côtés
des pêcheurs pour les défendre on n'est
pas dans une gestion d'une politique
commune des pêches qui d'ailleurs l'a
rappelé le plaisir d'un public
près après la présidence qui va être
pris par la france dans les prochaines
semaines il est important il a rappelé
qu'il souhaite que cette politique
commune des pêches soit beaucoup plus
humaine à la taille j'ai des raids de ce
que les professionnels de la filière
halieutique souhaite mettre en oeuvre
car aujourd'hui le poisson et les
ressources se porte bien dans les eaux
européennes et après tous les efforts
qui ont été accomplis par les les
pêcheurs et et dans leur ensemble et
donc il est indispensable aujourd'hui
que l'on puisse avoir la visibilité
surtout qu'on puisse permettre aux
professionnels de pouvoir développer
leurs activités d'entreprises non pas
avec des problèmes qui est soit qui
vient de l'union européenne mais plutôt
avec des solutions merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
olivier le nézet rappelle que vous êtes
un président du comité régional des
pêches de bretagne